hi guys it's quinn again and today on
the channel we're going to be talking
about the book
lovecraft country
[Music]
now lovecraft country was not at all
what i was expecting
when i heard the name now it wasn't
until i looked at the back of the book
that i realized at all what it was about
and i'll just read that for you guys now
chicago 1954 when his father goes
missing
22 year old army veteran atticus turner
embarks on a road trip to new england
to find him accompanied by his uncle
george publisher of the safe negro
travel guide
and his childhood friend leticia on
their journey to the manner of samuel
brathwight
heir to the estate that owned one of
atticus's ancestors
they encounter both mundane terrors of
white america
and malevolent spirits that seem
straight out of the weird tales
george devours so obviously reading that
i was super intrigued by it i'm
obviously black i'm obviously a science
fiction
and fantasy nerd and i figured this was
at least
somewhat related to the work of h.p
lovecraft but i didn't know exactly how
this book as i said really did
shock and surprise me now it says in the
back of this that the main character of
the book is atticus turner
but in reality this book is more like an
anthology that involves
several different characters that
interact with each other
but each chapter is like a monster of
the week
type weird tales story i've just always
found it really appealing the idea of
going on a different
adventure every week or every chapter
it's really really cool to me
all right so let's talk about what this
book is actually about like i said the
title
lovecraft country implies that it's in
some way related to the work of h.p
lovecraft now i didn't know if eldritch
horrors were going to appear or if like
people from lovecraft's universe were
going to
pop up or if it was a retelling of some
of lovecraft's stories
i had no idea what this was going to be
but it turns out that
it's only tangentially connected to
lovecraft
and what's actually happening is you're
having different people experiencing
different kind of paranormal
supernatural weird things um and they're
all encountering different weird things
they've all been put in circumstances
where weird things are happening around
them whether it's sorcery
whether it's weird technology that
involves like space travel or whatnot
and then of course there are some loose
lovecraft tie-ins so mainly where
lovecraft comes up
in this book is from within the universe
as a fictionalized author so this book
isn't
set inside of lovecraft's universe
lovecraft is an author
inside of this fictional universe just
like he is in ours so you have the main
character atticus who is a big fan
of all sorts of fantasy stories ray
bradbury
heinlein h.p lovecraft just as i am
and what gets interesting is his
knowledge of these stories and the ideas
in them
helps him at other places in the book
and it helps him deal with some of the
paranormal stuff
that's happening around him and around
the other people that this book follows
because it's not just about atticus
like i said it reads more like an
anthology with a bunch of different
characters
so you would expect that even though
this book is only tangentially related
to lovecraft
that there would still be some elements
of cosmic horror
or that that would be the main focus of
it but actually
no there's very little cosmic horror in
this book
just a little bit but not much the main
horror that this book focuses on
is racial horror and racial tensions
in america and i must say
i found the characters in this book
relatable and i was very moved by this
book on
a very personal level um i related to
atticus
immediately when the book opens up and
he's alone
driving in the south in kentucky getting
pulled over by
a cop you got this cop questioning
the books that are in in the backseat of
his car and going is this your card like
you're reading
science fiction and vanisly like this
and so
that resonated with me on a real level
because as a black nerd i'm constantly
having the things that i do
questioned it's like why why why are you
reading this and not this
it's like a constant act of having to
reprove who you are to people over
and over and over again and i definitely
related to atticus's struggle
tremendously i feel like i have to share
something about me
with you guys now i was born
in a southern county in georgia
most of my life i was raised by my
grandparents
now i essentially grew up on stories
of jim crow my grandparents told me
about having to go in the backs of
restaurants and ride on the backs
of buses my grandad has told me
incredible stories about racial
prejudice intentions that he's
experienced himself
i've experienced these racial tensions
you know in in the 21st century
i've never told this story on youtube
sort of in other places but never on
youtube
but i think if there was ever a time for
me to tell the story it would be in this
lovecraft country review
so this was my first year
of college at valdos to stay at universe
and i had driven to the comic book shop
with some friends
um we were playing some magic the
gathering rounds quite nerdy
affair got a little bit late my friends
were still inside
the comic shop it had gotten a little
bit dark i was pretty hungry
hadn't eaten all day so i walked over to
the burger shop or whatever the fast
food restaurant was
right across the street came back to the
comic book shop sat on the corner
started eating about
five or so minutes into me enjoying my
burger i look over and i see
this guy big guy white guy
kind of looking at me from across the
parking lot and i think
oh what's up this guy he's kind of kind
of staring me down like what's what's
the deal with that what's up
and i i think maybe i should like go go
say something to him go like wave at him
or say like hey what's up man or
or something because he's kind of
creeped me out a little bit staring at
me from a dark parking lot we're just
trying to like have like kind of
trying to eat you know minding my own
business and so i'm there and he's there
staring me down for about i don't know
five or so minutes looking really weird
i'm starting to get a little bit tense
and then my friends come out
of the comic book shop my wife friends
and as they're walking out he walks up
to them and starts
strikes up a conversation and also just
as they were walking out i was
finishing my meal and so i finish up and
i walk over to them
and i see him kind of look over at me
and kind of like
reach toward his side a little bit like
what what's going on and so i walk up
and i go hi and my friend say hi to me
and then he looks at them and he goes oh
he's with you guys
i thought i was gonna have to use this
for a second and he kind of
pulls up his jacket and shows his gun
and so immediately me and my two friends
were like kind of like
kind of freaked out i was just
sitting on the sidewalk sitting on the
corner outside a comic book shop eating
not being menacing
five minutes from campus minding my own
business
and for some reason to this guy i
looked dangerous enough suspicious
enough for him to think that he might
need to
shoot me and he felt the need
when i walked over to my friends and we
started talking to to show us his gun
and point
out that fact um
well needless to say we left immediately
and it was one of the scariest moments
of my life there's a few other stories
like that
growing up in georgia maybe one or two
that are a little bit worse
but that's the real experience of mine
and so reading this book
and seeing these black nerds
have such similar experiences and have
such
similar thoughts to the ones that i've
had in my very mind
is kind of just very very incredible
and very very impressive now matt ruff
the author of this book is a white guy
so definitely he must have interviewed a
bunch of black people because
these these characters seem too real so
many things about it just seem
too true so lovecraft country isn't
really scary
it's kind of like pulp fiction half
serious fun um there's a lot of
adventure
there's there's ghost there's witchcraft
there's creepy voodoo dolls
and like i said it is all wrapped
around these ideas of racial tension
and all the stories are in some way
rooted
in racial ideas because they're told
through the lens of black people living
in the 1950s
on a side note reading this book also
got me thinking
of a movie that i saw when i was a kid
called
tales from the hood right and i don't
know if you i don't know if anybody's
heard of this but tails from the hood
was like so
scary when i was a kid so in lovecraft
country
there is one chapter called horus and
the devil doll
uh there's this creepy voodoo doll
that's like hunting this kid down
and like torturing him or whatever it
reminded me tremendously of tales from
the hood because
there is a sequence where you have this
this plantation house that's being
bought by this
white politician who's really racist and
at some point this house was
a slave house where all the slaves got
killed and eventually got bought by this
voodoo lady
who supposedly put all the souls of the
slaves inside of the dolls
and so of course this guy moves in and
the dolls don't want him there
and it gets really creepy
where the [ __ ] did your little black ass
come from so definitely the sequence in
this book with the doll was very creepy
and also doubly it reminded me of
telstra because there's also a story
about a little boy
that draws monsters in the character
horus and this
is a comic book creator uh so you see
how many relate ways i relate i'm
literally a comic book creator horace is
a comic creator
i relate to all of these characters on
so many levels and not just horus in
atticus
hippolyta i found to be extraordinarily
relatable um her just desire she just
wants to see the star she just wants to
follow her dreams
and then also the character ruby
i felt had one of the most interesting
arcs
i don't want to spoil it completely
but the metaphor is quite
clear and that's something that a lot of
black people think about
i can attest to that what would it be
like
to live like that you know for a day or
for a week
and to to go about the world in that way
you know what would it be like
how would the world see you how will you
see the world
so that was something when i got to that
part of the book
the ruby chapter i i thought for a
second oh this kid might this
might not let's see what matt ruff does
with this right this this is
really easy to mess up and to get wrong
especially for a guy that has never
lived in black skin
but matt ruff like i said did his
research
very very good book very respectful very
real characters
one more interesting thing that i have
to talk about with love prep country
is the relationship between the
character atticus and his father
montrose when it comes to the books that
atticus chooses to read
now early on in the book there's an
interesting section where atticus is
talking about
growing up and wanting to read books by
white authors you know he's
robert heinlein ray bradbury
lovecraft and his father always bringing
him some reason
why the book was horrible the book was
racist the book had a horrible depiction
of black people or something
and the kid just enjoying stories i just
want to read stories you know
i just want to read stories and if i'm
being honest
i'm not 100 sure what ruff was trying to
say with that
but for me personally i think books
and stories and movies will always be a
product
of their time and that's not saying
let's forgive
authors for messed up beliefs that they
might have had
not saying that at all but i'm saying
that it is possible to separate
the art from the author where we can
sometimes it's not possible sometimes
there are writers whose
hatred or bigotry seeps into the writing
personally i don't feel like lovecraft
is necessarily one of them
all right so final words on lovecraft
country
now this book plays on a lot of
different kinds of horrors
other than racial tensions but that's
obviously
wrapped around everything it also kind
of genre hops a little bit there's some
weird sci-fi stuff going on and some
weird more
supernatural ghostly stuff i'll tell you
about one of my
personal favorite scenes involving the
character
montrose encountering hungry ghosts
i should say and these ghosts aren't
hungry for food
they're hungry for feeling
and basically what they want or what he
wants is for mantras to tell him a story
he wants to almost feed off of
montrose's pain
and so montrose basically starts telling
him the story about like when
things went really bad for his family
one night and there was like a bunch of
there was a race riot
violence essentially um there was an
attack by white supremacist
on his community essentially and the
curious thing
about the scene i think is the
underlying
metaphor so just check out this quote
here
the look of naked craving on winthorpe's
face
reawakened that inner voice get out it
told
montrose this ain't a man it's a vampire
and it's starving get away from it so
essentially what i think is going on
here is matt ruff is
making a metaphor about how
often we feed on drama and making a more
specific one about how
kind of white people might feed on black
trauma
i don't know if that's necessarily
what's going on but i think
as a wider whole we can talk about like
how humans
like to hear about other people's pain
like we watch sad movies we watch
documentaries about sad things that
happen in the world we read
messed up books about the holocaust and
all sorts of things
so i think what he's talking about is
the
weird part of us that's entertained by
other people's
suffering which is quite dark if you ask
me
all right and i think that's it for
lovecraft country like i said
great book i'm gonna watch the show i'm
gonna see if it's anything like the book
and then i'll be reviewing the show
probably next week
i can binge the show i had to get to the
book kind of slowly because there was a
lot of stuff to absorb
a lot of times i had to pause reading
this because it was kind of like over
the top
and the ways in which i was relating to
it it was like it felt almost
too real even though i live in 2020
and this is set in 1954.
but anyway thank you guys so much for
watching make sure you like and
subscribe for more quinn's ideas
and check out the lovecraft playlist on
my channel
peace out
wait a second someone's at my door it's
it's really late for someone to be at my
door
[Music]
definitely a weird hour for an amazon
package
i don't even remember a wood ring
anything
this box has so much weird stuff
[Music]
this thing looks dumb how silly i'm
[ __ ] hungry
i'm down this fridge
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you